ungeimpfte sind ab jetzt raus aus dem
deutschen bundestag müssen oben sitzen
auf einer extra tribüne auch sie sahra
wagenknecht jetzt bei bild live herzlich
willkommen frau wagenknecht
hallo ich grüße sie fühlen sie sich
aussortiert an den pranger gestellt
also ich hätte ja für vieles verständnis
wenn es tatsächlich dazu beitragen würde
infektionen einzudämmen also das
wünschen wir uns ja alle dass sich
weniger menschen anstecken weniger
menschen infizieren aber ehrlich gesagt
diese regel jetzt die trägt dazu
überhaupt nicht weil gerade seit der
verbreitung von omikron sieht man doch
dass auch doppelt geimpfte sich im
grunde genauso häufig infizieren wie
nicht geimpfte selbst gepostete können
sich infizieren auch das ist inzwischen
klar dass lkw hat ja zahlen darüber dass
jetzt aktuell etwa 86 prozent der
erwachsenen die sich mit omikron
infizieren geimpft sind das ist mehr als
die impfquote und unter solchen
vorzeichen eine solche regelung
einzuführen dafür fehlt mir wirklich
jedes verständnis fühlen sie sich
aussortiert weil meine frage also fühlen
sie sich da oben auch vor allen dingen
zwischen afg abgeordneten unwohl fühlen
sie sich an den pranger gestellt dort
na ja natürlich wird das auch politisch
instrumentalisiert und das ist denke ich
auch das hauptproblem dass es hier gar
nicht um pandemie einschränkungen geht
dass es nicht um infektionen geht
sondern dass es um stigmatisierung geht
und das betrifft ja nicht nur dass dem
bundestag und nicht nur das deutsche
parlament wir haben ja auf vielen ebenen
jetzt diese zweig regelungen ungeimpfte
werden können nicht mehr zum friseur
jetzt schon seit fast zwei monaten sie
können mit ihren kindern nicht ins
schwimmbad gehen sie sind komplett aus
dem öffentlichen leben ausgegrenzt und
man muss ja deutlich sagen die grundlage
für diese einführung von 2g regeln das
sollte man sich immer wieder ins
bewusstsein holen die war damals in
hamburg es waren gefälschte zahlen
gefälschte zahlen über angeblich sehr
sehr hohe instanzen bei ungeimpften und
angeblich sehr niedrige bei kämpften
heute weiß man wie diese zahlen zustande
gekommen sind nämlich dadurch dass man
viele fälle von denen man gar nicht
wusste ob die impfung ungeimpft einfach
den umkämpfen zugeordnet hat und ich
finde nachdem man das weiß und nachdem
inzwischen ja auch die zahlen völlig
andere sind sie sind immer noch nicht
verlässlich vom rk ii aber trotzdem sind
sie ja deutlich anders muss man doch
diese politik überdenken nicht nur im
bundestag sondern in der gesamten
gesellschaft jetzt sitzen sie da oben
wie alle anderen ungeimpften auf dieser
extra tribüne man schaut also auf sie
und weiß sofort okay die frau
wagenknecht ok abgeordneter und
abgeordnete xy sind bisher nicht geimpft
wird das ihrer meinung nach zu größerer
abneigung ablehnung gegenüber ihnen
allen führen oder zu größerer
solidarisierung
also ich hoffe dass die gesellschaft und
das viele menschen auch die inzwischen
dürften auch die gepostet sind doch sich
gewahr werden dass diese spaltung uns
nichts bringt und dass die ganze debatte
die darauf hinauslief die ungeimpften
sind schuld an der pandemie sind die
pandemie treiber sie sind die infektions
treiber dass das wirklich nicht stimmt
die impfung schützt gegen schwere
verläufe das ist aktuell eindeutig nach
den zahlen ablesbar aber das heißt eben
man schützt sich selbst wenn man sich
impft das muss dann auch jeder für sich
entscheiden
aber es ist kein fremdschutz ich schütze
niemand anderen weil ich kann trotzdem
menschen infizieren ich kann menschen
anstecken und deswegen gibt es für diese
stigmatisierung keine rechtfertigung und
ich hoffe sehr dass wir als gesellschaft
auch da wieder aus dieser situation
herauskommen dass ungeimpfte von
arbeitskollegen gemobbt werden dass
familien ungeimpfte ausladen weil sie
denken sie gefährden sich wenn
ungeimpfte bei feiern dabei sind das
stimmt nicht wir brauchen tests wir
müssen hoffen dass die schnelltests die
es eben jetzt gibt halbwegs verlässlich
sind dadurch kann man sich schützen wenn
man sich teste das ist sinnvoll das ist
auch richtig finde auch nicht finde
durchaus sinnvoll dass wir jetzt auch im
bundestag sagen auch geimpfte müssen
sich testen das ist alles unstrittig
aber diese ausgrenzung diese
stigmatisierung dieser dieses
inszenieren eines sündenbocks um vom
eigenen versagen abzulenken anderer
politiker ich glaube dass und hoffe dass
die bevölkerung das nicht mehr mitmacht
sie haben gerade diesbezüglich auch von
der politischen instrumentalisierung
gesprochen das gibt es ja auch auf der
anderen seite also dass ungeimpfte
abgeordnete ganz bewusst ihren
impfstatus ihre nicht impfung politisch
instrumentalisieren tun sie das auch
nein ich finde ich habe damals als ich
das erste mal dazu befragt wurde die
frage halt wahrheitsgemäß beantwortet
weil ich auch nicht findet dass man die
öffentlichkeit belogen sollte aber
eigentlich nervt es mich weil wenn ich
mich zu einem thema äußere sollte es
meines erachtens überhaupt keine rolle
spielen ob ich geimpft oder ungeimpft
oder gewesen bin viele sind ja auch
genesen teilweise wird das aber nicht
anerkannt wenn man keinen pcr test hat
oder wenn es eine längere zeit
zurückliegt also es ist ja sehr
differenziert wer alles um geimpft ist
und warum und ich finde eigentlich
sollte überhaupt keine rolle spielen ist
eine private entscheidung die jeder für
sich treffen muss wo also eine
risikoabwägung treffen musste sich
persönlich betrifft seine gesundheit
sein leben und ich finde es ganz schlimm
dass das jetzt in einer weise
politisiert wird in die öffentlichkeit
gezerrt wird man das betrifft ja auch
menschen die im normalen arbeitsalltag
sind seit 3g muss ich ja auch jeder
ungeimpfte outen und wird natürlich dann
auch im oft entsprechend behandelt und
ich finde das geht nicht also wir haben
in der bundesrepublik eine solche
tradition noch nie gehabt
gesundheitliche entscheidungen waren
immer private entscheidungen wir ächten
ja auch nichtraucher weil sie
möglicherweise irgendwann das
gesundheitssystem belasten könnten was
ja tatsächlich in bei den folgen von
rauchen auch der fall ist oder menschen
die großes übergewicht haben sondern wir
haben eigentlich immer das verständnis
gehabt solche entscheidungen über den
eigenen lebensstil über die vorlieben
die sind von den menschen zu treffen und
das ist ihre freiheit dass sie sie
treffen können und da hat der staat
weder zu reglementieren noch gehört das
irgendwie an den öffentlichen pranger
und ich finde zu dieser tradition
sollten wir zurückkehren danke an die
linken bundestagsabgeordnete sahra
wagenknecht die dort im bundestag gerade
steht dort darf sie stehen als um
geimpfte aber wenn man einmal hinter sie
schaut frau wagenknecht dort links
hinter den scheiben dort befindet sich
dann der plenarsaal unten dürfen sie
nicht sitzen aber dort gerade dürfen sie
stehen und mit uns sprechen herzlichen
dank für das gespräch danke frau
wagenknecht
sehr gerne